[Music]
in New Year same Florida news is
submitted by mr. worldwide do a Florida
accent Florida the same accent a Florida
what's the difference between tips that
was apparent bro extra bad no but they
got like hood Floridians those I don't
know what that is so actually knew what
I'm going there next week off I know
here the top five Florida crime
headlines in just the first two weeks of
2000 my lord that is so sad
New Year same me what's going on and
blueberries don't make noises that's why
they do they scream in your mouth first
one here the headline said Florida man
denies ownership of syringes found in
his rectum during jail strip search you
planted okay I don't know how that God
was the last time you guys saw a cop's
episode I love cops cops is still going
on till this [ __ ] you watch it so I
was that door yeah the body shop cuz
might have my [ __ ] got [ __ ] up and
then I was just sitting in there
watching it dude people still make the
same [ __ ] excuses not really for
drugs I don't think so it look [ __ ]
crisp it looked like HD and they got
like new cars in the background it's not
in standard def anymore yeah the same
[ __ ] excuses man like this dude I
guess I can like the Carolinas weed is
still like crazy illegal Oh so this dude
was caught with like a bag of weed like
this big firstly he says he goes so
what's this over he goes nah man
probably came out of your pants
or something or his pants baggy ass plug
dude I'm sure they were reefer no
absolutely not because it was super
crisp the big pan these don't work out
like that oh yeah some places are behind
still yeah but this vol had this big old
bag of weed and then all they can do is
laugh like how are you going to say that
this [ __ ] thing that came out not my
and then what he said after was
hilarious he goes not mine healed this
not yours ask my wife she puts this [ __ ]
in his pocket my wife but she right
there my wife oh hey no no I'm gonna
watch when I go home I watch this one
other thing it was kind of like cops but
it was it but it's a bit like it's like
a cops like docu reality series and then
they're trying to talk to the camera are
we're gonna try to trap this guy this
guy's is known to get like male
prostitutes whatever and so they were
scouting him and then finally they see
the two guys like meet up in the shadows
and then they surround my kid out of the
car whatever this guy comes out and then
he has red lipstick on his lip anyway
what I wasn't doing anything and he was
in the middle of dressing and like
turning into a girl yeah I was like
people are [ __ ] funny the best
episode that I saw was this dude he was
like smoking weed and the dude was so
[ __ ] high he didn't know no they hear
the [ __ ] joint lit then what this is
like god damn and the cops
cracking the [ __ ] up dude because he's
just so high out of his [ __ ] mic he
had no clue you got to do all the this
Steven Seagal ones when he's a cop Oh
Steven Seagal look up those if you ever
have spare time Steven Seagal as a cop
observe him just trying to talk to a
black person what are the but he's an
actual cop in like Oklahoma or something
to sheriff and then there's a TV show
around him doing police work like he
goes around one black dude it is [ __ ]
hilarity turns into like a jive Turkey
so he'll be right he goes well you know
there's a lot of people coming out here
than they're saying that they're not
doing their crimes and I'm just here to
catch him and also he sees one black
dude right yeah it's cuz what you try to
say homie what's going on
it's like whoa what the [ __ ] is going on
because Thompson grow did a stand-up
about it that's why I looked at her ah
and it's true he wasn't exaggerating is
that what you mean I put it on my mom
[Laughter]
with this [ __ ] yellow lenses the
syringe but dude his name is Wesley he's
40 years old let me talk like the locals
do oh he looks like a syringe Buddha so
sad that's someone's baby you know
what's crazy is that constabulary had
three syringes in his rectum a little
cap how did they pull the capsule they
usually put it in the condom ah they put
all everything in a condo I'll see you
answered Josh then I just pictured the
syringe like with the needle already but
then you could I guess you could undo it
in this way right cuz it's not attached
no yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah you could
like break you same break it down yeah
yeah yeah they should make a board game
called guess who and it's just the faces
of the inmates and then all the stuff
yeah Florida guess ooh and then of the
things that are found in the butthole
and then you have to match to see if you
can match the smoking gun cuz I follow
their facebook page sometimes they'll
post these games where you have to like
match the person to the crime and with
their mug shot yeah I spent so many
nights Harry
cuz he looks more like a shrooms guy
true but not not like syringes true
alright next headline headline Florida
man arrested after argument over
cheesecake I mean that's a David Krejci
think go cheesesteak
that's a David Craig not so much but why
would he get arrested over an art so he
said that he they say that he engaged in
a scuffle with the cashier oh they call
food cart over receiving a sesame seed
bun with his sandwich because he didn't
want a sesame seed bun
he was also heavily intoxicated so so
this is Joseph
as a white rectangle on his forehead oh
yeah they all look like GTA characters
but the old one like Gigi like two or
three yeah two or three like before yeah
oh my god I bet you GTA did like stay
studied [ __ ] mug shots and [ __ ] and
then for sure there's like a criminal
look I love cheesesteaks dude that's the
key to the Vexin says Florida man hit
dad in face with pizza after learning he
helped deliver him police say wait what
what's wrong with being delivered by
your dad I know but this Robert who's 33
years old he found out that his father
helped deliver him on the day of his
birth and then that made him smack them
in the face with the scalding hot slice
of pizza you deliver me like this pizza
what's the matter
and then no I don't know I was really
worried so his dad went out for an
evening stroll while he waited for the
pizza delivery when he came back he he
held him down in a chair he held his dad
down in a chair and slammed the slice of
pizza into his face while screaming at
him and if the victim began flailing
around and then he's trying to get the
defendant off of him and that's when he
went outside and waited for police
assault would a peeps and they said that
it ain't bad officials said that they
found a slice of pizza on a chair with
cheese and sauce being strewn about the
room
why is Robert another GTA character and
they all look like bad guys 30 why is it
that I got hungry I just pictured the
pizza and I'm tied up and I'm playing a
game like you're like super hot I like
honey I wish Pizza was better for you
pizza is literally one of the worst
things you could eat mmm
ever especially it is like the highest
fat the most highest carb content being
delivered but like if it's a if it's
artisanal pizza different no still
hotdogs are you
to do the macros I it is high in fat but
it's not as bad pizza still better in
general oak or food I agreed with that I
just saw it's a noiseless I'm gonna stop
talking cuz I'm drooling now oh yeah
here dude I like I like it so much that
I had a stomach flu the other day and
then the next day jess is like I want
some pizza and I was in the market
getting some likes then tell him what
you got
I got DiGiorno and I said you know what
I'm gonna send my stomach to health [ __ ]
it I mean you can't eat that the day
after you get the [ __ ] food poisoning
you know but then you said what you said
what what happened I ate and I fell
asleep no I think you felt good I felt
my mouth felt good but my stomach did
not Oh
as soon as I ate it I was like why
should I repeat oh you're just like this
is a mistake like know that maybe after
the first one I was feeling it and then
I was like I [ __ ] [ __ ] it [ __ ] it I felt
it go down my esophagus you know like
after you puke it's super tender
yeah and then like I started feeling it
on my stomach and I was like oh [ __ ] I
gotta go to sleep just was sitting on
the couch and and I went behind her back
and I fell asleep yeah yeah and I got up
and I was like alright cool
I'm gonna get another piece that's the
last thing I want when I'm puking and
[ __ ] I just can't think of food guys
bathroom we were eating [ __ ] and I was
like oh my god what the [ __ ] is
happening am I just ghetto ass and
Gabriel fun places yeah yeah I don't
even know how to react to it I'm like oh
my god am I gonna throw up oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna go and someone was in the girls
bathroom and I'm like [ __ ] it so I went
into the guys bathroom and I'm throwing
up in the sink and the guy walks in I'm
like dude sorry I'm pregnant he's like
nah do you think and he just can I have
that after you're done though he wasn't
an asian guy that's why I did the non
agent action
there wasn't strings of fun the whites
the meat was thank you think about that
don't chew at all what's wrong with me
oh you got the duck bit everything that
was in there [ __ ] it was like did you
just throw a ball in there or what
happened yeah question myself to you oh
my look I need a chew more piece of
brisket so this other one Florida woman
denied Outback Steakhouse the text
parents threatened to kill them I'd do
this thing I mean it's Outback
Steakhouse yeah you like it
I mean no no I mean like I would I would
not want to go there either oh this is
Deanna no she wanted to go and when they
refused her out back oh she crazy that I
don't know anybody that fighting around
a schoolteacher yeah this kind of maybe
took a little bit so it says that she
became so arranged over their denial to
take her to dinner that she started
turning over furniture smashing through
glass and who punched her her mother in
the chest and arms
she's a Tasmanian devil laughing how do
you mean white of a situation
I have no muscles in my arms that hurt
it was bony ass not much straight to
bone [ __ ] I'll punch at all next time
oh yes she was sorry she was charged
with aggravated assault with a deadly
weapon domestic battery and battery of a
person 65 or older and she is currently
awaiting mental health evaluation yeah
she's not gonna pass and then the last
one we actually just talked about which
is this man named Daniel was 41 he was
arrested after being upset for not
having a straw
we're not getting a straw straws for
life yeah but he got his ass beat no
[ __ ] that they shouldn't even send him
to jail because he already got his just
desserts
no I think you get [ __ ] up even yeah
everyone laughs a time for beating a
girl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]